[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec le temps
avec le temps va tout s'en va on oublie
le visage
nous n'oublie la voix le cœur quand ça
va plus c'est pas la peine d'aller
chercher plus loin faut laisser faire
[Musique]
avec le temps bas tout s'en va
l'autre qu'on adorait qu'on cherchait
sous la pluie l'autre con deviné au
détour d'un coquin
entre les mots entre les lignes sous le
phare d'un segment maquillé qui s'en va
faire sa nuit
et que le temps
tous s'évanouit
[Musique]
avec le temps
avec le temps va tout s'en va même les
plus chouettes souvenirs
à la galerie les rayons la mort le
samedi soir quand la tendresse s'en va
toute seule
avec le temps
temps avec le temps bas tout s'en va
l'autre à qui l'on croyait pour un rhume
pour un rien
l'autre à qui l'on tenait du vent et des
bijoux
pour qu'il en est vendu son
âme pour quelques sous devant quoi
annonce traînait comme traîne les chiens
avec le temps
tout va bien
[Musique]
avec le temps
avec le temps va tout s'en va on oublie
les passions et nos oublie la voix
qui vous disait tout pas les mots des
pauvres champs
[Musique]
surtout ne prends pas froid
avec le temps
avec le temps va tout s'en va et l'eau
se semblant chi comme un cheval fourbu
et l'on se sent glacé dans un lit de
bazar et l'on se sent tout seul
peut-être mais peinards
alors vraiment
avec le temps
on aime
[Musique]